unusually warm
and the impact of that increasingly
clear
we're getting more and more used to
seeing pictures like this
all tangible examples of our
ever-changing climate
and experts say it's only going to get
worse
and this is why the state of the climate
report now in its 31st edition reveals
how in recent years temperatures in
europe have been on the rise and in 2020
have reached 1.9 degrees above the
long-term average if we look at what
that's felt like in individual countries
many places particularly eastern europe
reported record high temperatures last
year russia was nearly three degrees
warmer than the average high that was
recorded between 1981 and 2010.
parts of western europe were relatively
cooler but norway nearly two degrees
above average and the uk we've had our
third warmest year since national
records began and those soaring
temperatures have also contributed to
rising sea levels with 2020 seeing the
record high for the ninth year in a row
sea levels rose more than nine
centimeters above the average back in
1993 that's due to warming oceans
melting glaciers and ice sheets so why
are temperatures going up well it's down
to record amounts of greenhouse gas in
the atmosphere peaking in 2020 in fact
the average concentration of co2 was up
48
on pre-industrial times and atmospheric
methane increased
160 percent during the same period and
this is the really difficult thing those
increases happened despite human co2
emissions decreasing by up to seven
percent during the pandemic so those
small but not insignificant changes made
no tangible difference to our
atmospheric co2 levels
these other emissions are going to come
from
things like power stations where they
are based on fossil fuels so coal and
natural gas we there were still some
flights for transporting goods and posts
for example so there are all kinds of
other emissions that we don't
necessarily see in our day-to-day lives
but are were still going on during 2020.
so that's the challenge how to hit our
global warming reduction targets and
scientists say the situation should
worry us all harriet hatfield sky news